all right let's try efore and see what
cubbies
is it cubbies or cubies I don't know I
always seem to hesitate okay so where
you got black throwing the caro-kann at
me and I really don't want to go
mainline so let's let's run and I didn't
want to well there's also the pan of Bob
for Nick right but I don't want to go at
that I like the exchange variation and I
actually learned something recently from
this variation I got beat up so right
here I believe I believe in response to
Bishop to g4 Queen to b3 is not correct
so I could maybe go over that a little
bit after the game but there's an
interesting line that somebody played
against me the other day so okay just
development right get those minor pieces
out get castled what would be a
purposeful move here I think rook to e1
a4 springs to mind and maybe neither of
the two you know I'm just something else
what about hmm-hmm
let's go with eighth floor actually I'm
trying to take into account the minority
attack that black may be wanting to
implement with a six and b5 and see what
they want to do they might want to
relocate this Bishop h5 to g6 and the
main reason for that is to negate this
bishops presence on the board so my
bishop coming under some heavy fire
right now and I don't think
have much choice so I'm gonna have to
part with my dark square Bishop but my
pot in my remaining pawns well my center
ones at least they're finding themselves
on dark squares so I have still control
over the dark squares or enough at least
and if the bishop were to ever take my
knight here I'd give some serious
thought to just recapture with the pond
followed up with King g2 and rook to h1
so that's something to be very aware of
right there capturing the knight
probably not a good idea unless like a
five could come to me immediately so I'm
not so sure about a five because again I
believe the the plan to be running with
four black is to get in this b5 move but
that's going to be a very difficult
thing to do now I think that this is a
good move Queen Queen here Queen to c2
or b1 yeah I think my opponent is
actually in some trouble right now I'm
not quite sure which of the two is
better I'm gonna go with the b1 just to
play extra cautious in the event the
replace here I don't have to worry about
Knight be for maybe Knight takes on D at
some point
so what else okay so this is this is the
problem right here because I believe g6
was needed yeah I believe g6 was needed
and so as to meet Knight h2 with g4 so
but now after Knight h2 I'm going to end
up winning upon so I'm just trying to
anticipate what the resulting formation
of pawns is gonna look like am I gonna
be coming under heavy fire because I
kind of am going well I'm definitely
going backwards but my first thought was
am I really going out of my way to go
ahead and pick up upon so Knight h2
Bishop back g4 Bishop g6 takes takes
takes
and then I'm actually hitting this guy
as well is there anything better you're
not really seeing it I think this is a
good idea to just pick up a pond here
maybe is there actually any rush with
them playing g4 I'm so sure I think it
is best to play back here and force me
to do g4 and you know if I get that pawn
at least what black gets in return is a
half-open F file right so okay this why
did I even consider this I didn't
consider that of course they could play
this and not even be down upon right oh
man
okay well if they're gonna be down there
light-square bishop shouldn't I be able
to make use of this this open diagonal
somehow all right let's see Knight takes
bishop or don't even take the bishop to
eat rookie
I'm gonna do this first I also should
probably move a little bit faster right
alright I am down on time and my
opponent is starting to fly ok I gotta
take this guy and let's um no no no no
let's come over here real quick um
hitting this hitting this guy right here
and I guess this move is gonna be needed
it's not really turning out how I
planned is it that's my kid doing all
these calculations yeah I'm gonna be up
a pond but I'm not so sure that the
resulting formation well the resulting
formation I'm not liking so much and I'm
not so sure with this clown thinks he's
doing here and I'm not I'm not talking
about my phone I'm talking about this
night because once he gets to e3
actually let's do this I think I'm gonna
need some even more support for this pun
what I was gonna say I should probably
finish my thoughts it's not the easiest
thing to always do but after night to e3
it's like well so much for any pressure
I might have against this pun so that's
what's making me kind of rethink things
and I'm really not liking the fact that
I have to like going to like a giant
ball right here so let's let's get this
night doing something else
hopefully these minor pieces can't get
working too easily I'm really don't even
know what this guy's future is I see
very little future for this night
very very little yeah it's not happening
so hello to those coming in that in the
twitch chat okay this is a bothering me
really not liking this okay let's come
back here I think I'm gonna need to go
into defensive mode I'm doing this move
primarily to defend against h4 and then
try and get this guy if my knight if my
knight can get here then it's gonna make
a whole world of difference in fact in
fact this is what I'm gonna do what a
sad thing to do but I'm gonna do it my
knight is officially going to be a
defensive piece and I should actually
you could come here with threats right
why didn't I think to pinpoint that Wow
look at f2 what sir was it really worth
taking that light square bishop probably
not another thing to be aware of is that
there's Bishop takes pawn but my knight
and rook are there to watch over f1 so
that's another thing I had to be
cautious of one thing I don't want to do
is play play my rook here cuz then
Bishop snips this guy and it's not
really gonna be too fun for me in the
meantime what do I do
yeah I guess we'll double up here put
more pressure on this guy right okay 33
seconds to go really fast okay this is
getting scary okay this is very very
scary very very very scary I feel like
I'm gonna be losing tactically I am on
this pawn but no it's actually covered I
could take here a couple times maybe I
should have just done that because
actually at the end of it okay let's
take him out at the end of it what's
going on man
I'm gonna go here I'm actually dropping
a pond right or something by getting
made it it's like I'm getting made it oh
please don't let it be me
Bishop takes g3 yeah that guy's ok let
me try this I did that move because I
didn't want this pawn to fall with check
let's come back here actually and my
opponent is playing a very nice here and
I gotta go quick really quick it's
actually come back and that my knight is
dead look at my knight
I got a primo a bunch of times and it's
not happening is it hopefully don't take
on b2 oh can I get a fork give a check I
have to come back actually
two point two seconds oh oh zero
ah that was a good pre move to be
running with the rook move point one
good game cubbies uh I couldn't get it
in there alright let's look over it this
turned out to be not a good choice let's
see what do we got so so far so good
right this has all been here before
oh so nothing nothing exciting here
right my opponent has their light-square
bishop outside the pawn chain and what
else I'm trying to take into account the
b5 move
should I have played Age 3 here beef did
not allow the dark square bishop
exchange I thought I would be alright
with that
know what else so this is apparently
where I'm going wrong right because
taking this bishop is just leading to
this F pawn taking a beating right I
don't know it seems like um hmm
it just seems so appealing to want to
take here but I guess I guess that
half-open F file really beat me up bad
and my opponent do really well with the
the continuations I'm you know watching
over east six so I think there's
something better than taking the bishop
alright let's see page three for some
reason I had a mental block I was
thinking that g6 was needed
they say just he just six is good enough
nine h2 and then f5 I completely for
sometimes I think and that Bishop just
has to run away but it doesn't so after
the Bishop backs or f5 is played rook e1
okay and then rook there should I have
just played f3 and then um f3 and then
well no actually I don't even like f3
because I'm subjecting g3 to some
problems right I don't have my dark
square Bishop so that's actually a
little bit scary too huh Wow because
this is a big the reason by the way the
reason why I'm kind of gravitating
towards this particular position is
because this is where there was that
last pond exchange right that was where
there was a structural change and so
those are often going to be very
critical points this right here is no
exception and so was it really worth
getting that light square bishop was I
really able to put my light square
Bishop to work I don't think so
so yeah no no there's definitely
something wrong with this I think cuz my
opponent has this well defended in his
cup in is how well this this column what
does this not even do I can't get this
night working where is the outpost form
F to F phloem age - he did a lot of
dancing and now I have to defend F - my
opponent is putting a lot of pressure on
me I don't have any I don't have any
successful pawn break although right
here maybe I should have run what just
takes I'm afraid to actually move
because I think that won't let me get
through the right remainder of the game
so I guess just having to visualize a
little bit I guess I could take take cuz
I would be on this in fact that was the
thing that so that's the improvement
right
so just take the pond take the pond for
some reason well what I do I threw my
kingdom know I didn't throw my king in
the corner oh and at this point right
here I ran away my bishop that's
ridiculous I should have realized that
this ensuing threat right here against
that pond would be quite good so a
missed opportunity maybe for me and so I
think for black maybe they shouldn't
have done that but I don't know I forget
what the time situation was but um yeah
a good game you put a lot of pressure on
me and I was doing a lot of dancing my
King I was having 0/0 play right here
and you played really sob this is a nice
consolidating move you know just taking
into account just what you know
practical play right here you just want
to find it find a move that's safe you
know it strings all your pieces together
etc and that these are all a lot of them
are just free moves and I lost point one
point one four cubbies okay this was the
winner right here in this time scramble
rook to be one that that chopped off I
think two seconds off my clock that was
good all right